chers amis, nous sommes des cosmonautes de roscosmos
sergey ryzhikov et grillons chat sergey
bienvenue à bord international
station spatiale
aujourd'hui, nous sommes avec vous pour commencer 2020
une année qui est devenue un test sérieux pour
toute la planète mais nous sommes tous des habitants de la terre
une fois de plus prouvé toute pandémie impuissante
si toute l'humanité s'unit dans
lutter pour la chose la plus importante que nous ayons
la vie cette année est devenue un anniversaire pour notre
orbital domestique international
station spatiale il y a 20 ans
la première internationale
équipage de membres de l'équipe alors amicaux
L'ISS a fêté ses 20 fêtes du Nouvel An ici
Nous avons la chance d'avoir des vacances
être ici au seuil d'un nouveau 21
aujourd'hui, nous voulons souhaiter à tous les résidents
notre pays multinational et le monde
prenez soin de vous et de vos proches restez en bonne santé
se considérer et être ensemble
c'est la chose la plus importante parce que nous sommes ensemble
nous surmonterons tout
bonne année